good morning good afternoon good evening
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
cancer biomarkers in the breath i'm
alexis krause of labbert
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labbert
and sponsored by agilent for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
agilent.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a
question box and click on the submit
button you can also submit any technical
issues here as well
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr michael phillips
professor of medicine at new york
medical college and ceo of mensana
research
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen michael
welcome sir
you may now begin your presentation
well thanks very much for the
introduction i'm going to be speaking
today about
cancer biomarkers in the breath now
breath tests have been
around for a very long time in fact they
started in ancient greece
hippocrates more than 400 bc said
to his students smell your patient's
breath
well you can tell a lot by smelling
somebody's breath
for example patients with diabetes their
breath smells like
rotten apples that's mainly because of
acetone
patients with kidney failure have a
urine-like smell in their breath
that's because of amy's patients with
liver failure have this wonderful
expression
fetal hepaticus the stench of the liver
mainly due to sulfur compounds
patients with a lung abscess have a
sewer-like smell in their breath
they smell like sewers for the same
reason that sewers smell like sewers
because of the overgrowth of anaerobic
bacteria
and finally nutrients you can tell if
any of your colleagues have had any
garlic or alcohol for breakfast
fast forward two thousand years to
france in the late 1700s which was the
dawn of the scientific period of breath
testing
lavoisier the father of chemistry was
the first man to discover carbon dioxide
in the breast
now if you look at this picture you can
see music standing on the left
on the right is madame de voisier
recording it all for posterity
there's this unfortunate subject sitting
down blowing through this high
resistance system
and this gentleman is blowing through a
large container of lime water calcium
hydroxide
and after he's been huffing and puffing
for several minutes they observed a
fine milky white precipitate in this
container
this is calcium bicarbonate now this was
the first
evidence that human beings excrete
carbon dioxide in their breath
kids do it at grade school these days
but back in the late 1700s
this was hot news this was the first
evidence that human beings
take in food burn it metabolically and
put out carbon dioxide as a product
this in fact is really the basis of our
whole understanding of biochemistry
and of human metabolism unfortunately it
didn't do lavoisier much good he had his
head cut off in the french revolution
that had nothing to do with breath
testing that was because of his day job
as a tax collector
fast forward another couple of hundred
years and the modern period dawns
in of all places indianapolis on new
year's eve 1938
which was the first time that balloon
breathalyzers for alcohol were deployed
and this they found is a very effective
technique that's still with us to this
day
and to identify revelers who may be
reveled a little bit too much
the modern period though of
microanalysis of breath started in 1971
with linus pauling not only had did he
win
two nobel prizes he also performed the
first microanalysis of breath
what he did was he concentrated normal
human breath in a cold trap
and then analyzed it with gas
chromatography which was a fairly new
technology at the time
and he discovered that normal human
breath contained more than 100 vocs or
volatile organic compounds
all in very low concentrations around
about parts per billion
now how do these compounds get into the
breath
well you can think of the lung is
containing an alveolar membrane
and i've shown it here as a tennis court
because if you spread out the
alveolar membrane in the normal human
lung it's very large
it covers an area roughly the size of a
tennis court of more than 100 square
meters
and this permits volatile organic
compounds to be entailed from the air
such as volatile anesthetics and it
comes from the air
across the membrane into the blood or
also go in the opposite direction
such as ethanol goes from the blood into
the air
one breath these days we know contains
more than 2 000
different volatile organic compounds
i have broken down the technical
challenges to breath testing into three
categories
first we have to collect the breath
sample then we analyze the breath vocs
and then we interpret the data
now you might think that collecting the
breath sample was the simplest part of
it all but in fact it's really the most
difficult
you might think well anybody can blow up
a balloon the problem is
is that breath biomarkers are exhaled in
parts per billion concentration
which means that even in so-called clean
balloons background contamination is a
problem
you can buy very expensive clean tedlar
bags but they're not really clean
when you get down to levels of parts per
billion
so let's go back to indianapolis 1938 do
you remember the breath balloon
now that balloon was way too dirty for
volatile organic compounds in past per
billion
the reason is that these balloons are
contaminated with plasticizers
and adhesives however we developed a way
to make these balloons or any balloons
chemically clear
what we've done is we've gone back to
the future we've taken a very old
technology
and we've developed this device called
the breath bag which is free of
volatiles at parts per billion
levels here's the secret
well it's not really a secret of course
it now has a u.s patent
but we take a regular balloon and we put
into it a strip of paper that's
impregnated with activated carbon
this strip sucks up all the volatiles in
the bag
and if we leave it there overnight and
then remove the strip before collecting
the breath
we find that that bag is chemically
planned down to past pavilion levels
and this for the first time has provided
low-cost high-quality
technology for collecting breadth
volatiles
it's now possible then to mail in breath
tests we can send this out as a kit to a
user
they they inflate the balloon
and then send it back to the lab for
analysis
so that brings us then to the second
step analyze the breath volatiles
there are several different ways of
doing this the method that's really the
method of choice in most labs these days
is to use gas chromatography
gas chromatography provides a long
column which separates out all the vocs
and as they come out at the end of the
column it can then be detected with
various different kinds of detectors
such as mass spectrometry flame
ionization detection
or surface acoustic wave detection
however there are other methods of
measuring compounds in the breath
you've probably heard of e-noses or
electronic noses sniffer dogs do a great
job of it
and so too does infrared spectrometry
but for most laboratory applications
gas chromatography is really the method
of choice
when you use this with some advanced gas
chromatographs
here's a chromatogram using
two-dimensional gas chromatography with
time-of-flight mass spectrometry
you see a huge number of samples here
via peaks i should say
we see more than two thousand different
volatiles in a single breath
this is excellent for biomarker
discovery but a bit expensive for
routine use one of these instruments
will set you back more than three
hundred thousand dollars
we use now what we call the breath x
system which provides very
low cost analysis using a surface
acoustic wave detector
the first step as you see in the top is
to collect the sample
we use the ultra clean balloon very
simple to use it can be used anywhere
say in a home or a clinic
this is then used either at the point of
care or it can be sent to a lab for
analysis
to analyze the sample using a
user-friendly instrument with automated
analysis
the results of that chromatogram are
then analyzed a server applies
algorithms for different diseases
sends a report to the user and this
cycle can be completed
in approximately 10 minutes
now this is a video showing how we
actually analyze the sample
in the lab you see the technician takes
the bag
and cuts off the tip of it
and puts the bag over the intake nozzle
of the gas chromatograph
that device sitting on the left is a gas
chromatograph with the surface acoustic
wave detector
and you can see that that bag is
deflating because the pump
inside the gas chromatograph is pulling
out the sample
and capturing it onto an internal trap
which has got
10x and that's completed after
approximately two minutes
and then the instrument automatically
switches over and puts the sample
through the chromatography column it's a
fairly short column only about a meter
so results you see the results very
quickly and the peaks start coming out
very promptly so we'll just watch that
for a few seconds
and after approximately
30 seconds it's half done and takes
about two minutes to be completed
and you can see this is a two minute
chromatogram
we see approximately 50 to 60 vocs it's
not sensitive it's these
big bench top devices but that's
generally good enough
for most clinical applications the third
task here is to interpret the data the
challenge
is to find the signal buried in the
noise because
we're using modern technology we're
going to see thousands of different
volatiles in that bag but only maybe
10 or so of them are significant for a
particular
application such as being a cancer
diagnostic
how do we do that i'm going to show you
more about that and we're starting
now with the breath test for lung cancer
the background to this is that this
publication appeared in the new england
journal of medicine in 2011.
it came from the lung cancer screening
group and they reduced they reported
reduced lung cancer
lung cancer mortality with low-dose
computed serotomographic screening
this was a huge study it had more than
53 000 subjects
they randomly assigned people to be
screened either with chess ct or
ldct low-dose chassis tear or off the
chest x-ray
and they found that they could reduce
mortality 20 percent
in the group that had a chest ct now
this was regarded as very big news
indeed
and has resulted in a huge expansion in
screening programs
however lung cancer screening does have
some problems
many of the smokers who need ldct often
don't get it
because they fear the test they feel the
radiation has it
it's got a very low yield it takes more
than 50 of these chest cts to find one
cancer
it's insensitive to early disease
because it doesn't pick up lesions much
smaller than one centimeter in diameter
and by which time the cancer has got
more than 10 to the 10 cells in it
also it has a high false positive rate
and that's resulted in a lot of
over investigation and over treatment
now consider what actually happens in
the lung lung tissue damage of any cause
can do two things it causes a lesion
that's visible on ldct
but it also causes oxidative stress
now an oxidative stress the cell starts
manufacturing
reactive oxygen species or free radicals
and these are compounds that have got an
unpaired electron in the outer valence
shell these are very very powerful
oxidizing agents
and you see here what's happened with
polyunsaturated fatty acids pufas
in cell membranes these are oxidized and
then broken down in a series of steps
and at the end of this series of steps
it's broken down to much simpler
compounds
alkaline straight chain in alkanes such
as tentain
methane and so on and these are excreted
in the breath
where they provide biomarkers of disease
we've reported several studies of breath
tests for
lung cancer over the years however
even though these tests were a bit
different and all of these studies were
different
the experimental design was essentially
very similar
in all of these studies we started out
with two groups
the subject group and this is a group
that's got cancer that's proven by a
biopsy
under a microscope so we know that
really is cancer and a control group
that has got no cancer at all
we then go through two phases the model
building phase which is unblinded
and the model testing phase which is
blinded in the model
building phase we identify the accurate
biomarkers of cancer
and then we combine them into a
predictive algorithm
then we go on to the model testing phase
and we test the accuracy
of that algorithm usually in a new set
of subjects
and we want to determine their
sensitivity specificity and predictive
value
and i'm going to explain what all of
those terms mean
now first thing we have to do is
identify the accurate biomarkers
and the way we do it is we display the
data in what's called a receiver
operating characteristic or a rock curve
and this is a plot of the percentage of
true positives
versus the percentage of false positives
or we can re-enable that
the percentage of true positives is the
sensitivity of the test
and the percentage of false positives is
one minus specificity
this curve gives us an enormous amount
of information
about whether your test is any good or
not
now if it's a straight line like this an
area under curve at 0.5
then your test is really no good at all
because it's not giving you any
information
any more than just flipping a coin it
could be either way
just p less than 0.5 however
as that test gets better for any reason
when you're up to 0.6 you're now to a
fair test which is
not bad it's like psa and screening for
prostate cancer
then 0.7 reasonable test
like most we use in clinical medicine
0.8 now a very good test
0.9 an excellent test and one
a perfect test because at that point in
the top left hand corner
you can see the true positive rate is
100 and the false positive rate
is zero however
there's always a problem here you're out
for a walk one evening you look up at
the sky you think
look there's a face in the clouds
warning
beware of seeing faces in the clouds and
the reason is that faces in the clouds
we know are illusions
similarly many statistically significant
biomarkers
can also be illusions simply because
their very large data sets
can throw up apparently significant
biomarkers just by chance alone
now this has been seen in many areas of
research neuroscience not just in breath
testing
and has gained the name of voodoo
biomarkers how do we avoid having a
voodoo biomarker
well there's a statistical solution and
the method we use is what's known as
monte carlo simulations
that's to say we take the whole data set
and instead of applying the correct
diagnosis of cancer or no case
cancer we randomly assign the diagnosis
to disease or no disease
now when we do that we get a plot if you
look on the x-axis here
this is the c statistic or the area
under curve of the biomarker rock curve
and on the y-axis this is the number of
candidate biomarkers
now initially when we've done our random
accuracy with the monte carlo
simulations
just randomly assigning to disease or no
disease this is what the curve looks
like
you start up with a very large number of
biomarkers and then it falls to zero
then we compare that to what are we
saying
will you use the measured accuracy with
the correct diagnosis
if these two curves overlap then you're
really in trouble
because it means that you have no
biomarkers that are better than random
alone
however if these two curves are
different as they are here
you take the point where the random
curve has fallen to zero
and the difference between the two
curves here shows you the biomarkers
with the accuracy
that are better than chance alone and
that overcomes the problem of voodoo
biomarkers
we published a study a volatile
biomarker in breath predicts lung cancer
and pulmonary nodules this came out in
the journal of breath
research in 2019
this was an nih funded blunder blinded
multi-center validation
study it was monitored with good
clinical practice
and as before we had two groups the
training set and the validation
set and using the methods i've just
described we identified a mass iron
biomarker of abnormal
chest ct so we've identified a biomarker
which we called
magic and that stands for mass
abnormalities
in gaseous ions with imaging correlates
and magic we found is a biomarker of an
abnormal ldct
it's defined by its retention time on
gas chromatography
and also by its mz ratio of the mass
ions and that stands for
mass over charge we're not 100 sure of
what magic actually is but we've
identified it attentively from the nist
library
it appears to be a five carbon alcohol
and it's consistent with an oxidative
stress product
now when we evaluated the clinical
accuracy of magic
you can see here two curves i've shown
you on the rock curve
the red and the blue there are two
different laboratories we analyzed the
same sample split samples from the same
patients and you see the results were
really very similar
that in the area under curve was
0.81 and 0.77 very similar indeed
which means we got very good results
with two separate laboratories
analyzing the same samples
so where we stand with the magic
biomarker we did the blinded study
we did duplicate essays at two different
laboratories
and it accurately predicted lung cancer
and chest ct
here's where we stand with the breath x
test for magic biomarker
we had to apply it for pre-screening to
predict risk of an abnormal chest ct and
lung cancer
the current status is that u.s patents
have been issued and pending
it has a ce mark in the european union
clinical validations are in progress
and we hope eventually to submit this to
fda for approval
let's move on now to a breath test for
breast cancer
why is it needed i need to explain to
heavily male audiences
that most women hate having a mammogram
there's a number of reasons for that
it's painful they feel the radiation and
it can be embarrassing they have to get
undressed for it
the other thing about mammography is
that it is a very
low yield test now in this
diagram here i've shown you 300 women
represented symbolically who are going
in for a screening mammogram
of these 300 women 30 of them
will have a positive result that is the
mammogram will be reported as
suspicious for breast cancer they'll be
called back for repeat views
and of this then they'll find six that
still look pretty suspicious
suspicious and they go on to biopsy and
of these
one has cancer that's right 300 patients
to discover one case of cancer
the other side of it is think about
those 299 women who don't have cancer
they have to undergo radiation
discomfort anxiety
expense and all they get at the end of
that is reassurances
by the way you're not the one in 300
who's got breast cancer
well in 2018 we've we reported our
first clinical evaluation of the breath
x system though we had done a number of
studies prior to this of breast cancer
we reported prediction of breast cancer
with volatile
uh biomarkers in the breath
we did these tests in 178 women we had
two groups
one with biopsy proven breast cancer the
other
no cancer normal mammograms did this in
three sites in
one in mexico two in the united states
and we compared two methods
gcms and gc saw
this is the number of human subjects we
had i shall go through that
and here's the results this is the rock
curve and you'll see
the blue here was with gc mass
spectrometry
the red is gc sore not much difference
between the two of them
0.9 and 0.86 both of them giving
excellent results
these are the best results yet reported
for a cancer breath test
and just put a bit of comparison in this
if you compare this say to a mammography
with film or digital mammography they
generally reported around about 0.78
so the test the breath test is at least
as good as
and possibly better than a screening
mammogram
this is the expected outcome if we
screen large populations
you need to know two things the positive
predictive value and the negative
predicted value
the positive predictive value is the
true positives divided by
all positives such as the true positives
plus false positives
the negative predictive value is true
negatives divided by all negatives that
is true negatives and false negatives
when we do that we make a plot of the
positive predictive value
now what comes out when we analyze the
breadth is what's called the
discriminant function
that is the algorithm applies a
uh interprets the chromatogram and
generates a number that is called the
discriminant function
and you'll see here that it goes on
about one two four
and as it starts off very low and then
suddenly jumps up
so the ppv increases with the df or
discriminative function value
and eventually rises to 100 percent
now look at the negative predictive
value this is important because the
negative predictor value is a rule out
test
it tells you if the person does not have
cancer and you'll see
that it starts off very high and then
falls down
and the negative predictor value is
better than 99.9
at very low values of the discriminant
function
so based on this you can see that the
risk of breast cancer
increases with the discriminant function
generated by the breath test
so as we start off from low to high
so does the risk of breast cancer
increase
it stratifies the risk into three
separate groups
if the discriminant function is less
than one then there's a very low risk of
breast cancer
with a negative predictive value better
than 99 percent
green light very low risk
what if the discriminant function
function is greater than three
well then there's a high risk of breast
cancer
red light and that patient should be
investigated further
but if it's intermediate between one and
three it's an intermediate risk
well that's an ambolite and what we can
do is just follow up
so here's our conclusions the breath
tests have detected breast cancer
several studies not just our laboratory
have reported that breath biomarkers of
breast cancer
and it's been shown in different
laboratories using different methods
the potential benefits is that it could
provide an accurate new cancer screening
tool
resulting in fewer and needless
mammograms women would benefit because
they'd have no discomfort and no
radiation
and the health care system benefits from
lower costs
i want to conclude with breath tests for
biomarkers of radiation exposure
now the reason i include it here is that
radiation therapy for cancer is very
commonly employed
and there is a very variable biological
response to radiation
in people who have chest radiation
approximately a third of them will
develop
radiation pneumonitis or serious
inflammation in the lungs
and this is unpredictable and
life-threatening so the solution could
be a breath test for radiation
biodosimetry
that predicts the actual biological dose
of radiation
the method here is that we're going to
validate breath biomarkers of radiation
exposure
we're doing this in two phases in
animals to confirm the proof of proof of
principle
and in humans to validate the dose
response to radiation
our long-term hope is perhaps we could
predict radiation pneumonitis we haven't
achieved that yet
the scientific basis for this is that
radiation
of water generates free radicals and
causes oxidative stress as we've seen
previously
this oxidizes the polyunsaturated fatty
acids to n
alkanes and again we see volatile
organic compounds
excreted into the breath as biomarkers
of radiation
we've published several papers on this
in we've initially studied the getting
in minifig
and we've also done this in human
studies as well
we recently completed an animal study
in collaboration with our colleagues at
agilent
who provided us with a gc mass spec with
mass spectrometry and flame ionization
detection for this study
and this is what a breath chromatogram
looks like by the way you can see the
instrument there
and this is what a typical breath
chromatogram looked like
in our test animals these were non-human
primates
just with the naked eye you can see
approximately 50 peaks in that
chromatogram
but there's several peaks in there that
are too small to be seen but a computer
algorithm picks them out very nicely
and we can see anywhere up to about 200
different peaks
now we looked at five non-human primates
in this particular study and i'm showing
you here the
average chromatogram the mean of the
five chromatograms
before and after radiation in blue
this is the mean chromatogram of breath
before
radiation and here in red
is the mean chromatogram after radiation
well you don't need statistics here you
can see that radiation produced some
pretty dramatic changes
however we did of course go through all
the steps that i've outlined before such
as the monte carlo analysis
and we found that many of these changes
were statistically significant
and here's where we stand with the
breath test for radiation
the pilot studies were successful in
animals and humans
the biomarkers were consistent with
oxidative stress products
and the hope is maybe it could predict
radiation pneumonitis
and we are planning larger validation
studies in humans
however of course i must emphasize at
this stage this is for research use only
it is not an fda approved test
now this is the point in my presentation
where usually i can hear members of the
audience stirring restively
and saying well if breath tests are so
good
why isn't everybody using them already
well there's a reason for it i have
represented a breath test as a leaping
lion here
this is the men's sound of breath says
and that leaping lion wants to get its
jaws into this juicy piece of meat here
the market but in order for the breath
test to reach the market
it has to jump through free flaming
hoops
the first two is to demonstrate
scientific validity which we've done
the second hoop is to get fda approval
which we haven't
and the third step is to get medicare
reimbursement which you can't get
without
fda approval
so this process by the way is much
easier outside the united states
because there are much lower regulatory
barriers in the european union
and we are very close to marketing the
breadth test for breast cancer
in europe and indeed we have three
studies commencing there as we speak
so here is where we stand with breath
testing we have a very long product
pipeline
some of them closer to fruition than
others and you'll see that we've
included lung cancer
tuberculosis breast cancer influenza
counter-terrorism
we've got many tests in the pipeline
some
closer than others and we do hope the
cancer test will get there first
so thank you for listening so patiently
and i hope you will agree with me
quickly
that this is this is taking take
economic technology
oh we've got a few we've got a few
minutes left we're asking for questions
thank you michael for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started michael our first
question is
how can a breath test tell the
difference between lung cancer
and breast cancer if they both use
biomarkers of oxidative stress
very good question and the reasoning
behind this
is that people have assumed for the
longest time that oxidative stress was
just one simple procedure that is you
were got it and
generated a number of metabolites what
we've discovered over the years in the
course of all this research
is that oxidative stress is a highly
modulated
process so that even though we're
invoking
oxidative stress let's say in breast
cancer and in
lung cancer we do see a bunch of
metabolites and biomarkers which
are consistent with oxidative stress
products but they are distributed in a
totally different fashion
so the pattern of these products which
are not just alkanes but also
methylated alkanes and alkane
derivatives even though the rules
derived from oxidative stress come out
in a totally different pattern
so that the algorithms we derive let's
say for lung cancer
are totally different from those that we
see in breast cancer
and we see this right across the board
even with infections and radiation
even though yes we ascribe the outcome
to oxidative stress
the patterns are completely different in
every disease that we look at
great thank you so much so moving on to
our next question
might breast test be used for other
cancers such as gi tract cancers or
perhaps
liver or pancreatic cancers
the answer to that is absolutely yes
there's a very large literature on this
it mainly comes from european
researchers as well
but indeed there have been a number of
pilot studies in humans
showing positive results in gi tract
cancers
certainly pancreatic cancers as well
so and in head and neck cancers so
there's been a lot of research ongoing
in this a lot of publications
and the answer is definitely yes
wonderful we do want to thank our
audience for all these questions coming
in today
so moving on to our next one now can
breath tests
detect infections like covid
once again the answer is definitely yes
we haven't studied covert
in our lab but a number of other
researchers have done so
and they've reported some very positive
encouraging results with it
we have looked at patients with
infer infections such as viral influenza
and we've definitely seen biomarkers of
viral influenza and also of
um coronaviruses as well but we have not
looked at
coverts specifically but the answer is
definitely yes it could potentially be
used
for covet screening wonderful
so here we we received a similar
question to this
um a moment ago um in regards to you
know are there other opportunities
um for detecting different types of
cancer
so with this next question is you know
which cancers can we detect by breath
right now and
you know what about the specificity of
cancer detection
well uh let's address that question of
specificity
that's exactly what we look at in the
rock curve because you see that is
a plot of sensitivity versus specificity
so that we know that if you pick the
sweet spot on that rock curve
you can get a very good combination of
sensitivity and specificity
you can make that test 100 specific but
then you
there's a trade-off you lose some
sensitivity vice versa
you can make the test 100 or close to it
sensitive but then you lose some
specificity
this is just the trade-off that you see
whenever you've got a cancer test or
indeed any test where you can display
the results on a rock curve
and now in what way do the metabolites
of environmental pollutants
can they interfere with the breast test
for cancer
done quite a bit of work with
environmental pollutants as have many
other people
this was pioneered by the environmental
protection agency some years ago back in
the 60s and 70s
and they showed in very large studies
around the united states
that a breath test can pick up lots of
environmental pollutants
particularly btex compounds such as
benzene
and toluene etc and
it's a very sensitive test for exposure
to environmental pollutants
now the question really focuses here
does it
interfere with the tests for cancer or
other diseases and the answer is yes it
could
provide but it doesn't if you have a
really
good analytical method that is why we
use
mass spectrometry and if you tune your
method really right
you can tune out the interfering
compounds so that it doesn't overlap
with the biomarkers
it is a threat you know there is a
potential
for it to happen but if you're very
careful with the analytic technique
you can make sure that the peaks for
various compounds such as benzene and
toluene
come out at different places from the
biomarkers
thank you so much for that clarification
so moving on to
our next question so dr phillips how
reproducible can this technique be and
the second part of the question is could
it be marketed as a turnkey lab
well take the second part first yes of
course it could
how reproducible well we did a very
careful reproducibility study
if you recall the slide i shared about
lung cancer
we took duplicate samples from something
like 500 patients
and analyzed them in two separate
laboratories
now of course both laboratories were
using the same technology they were both
using
gc mass spectrometry and we went to a
lot of trouble before the study started
to make sure that these instruments had
similar
responses to compounds but you saw
when we analyzed similar split samples
from two uh from subjects 500 subjects
and we put them into two different
laboratories the results were remarkably
similar
the rock curves just about overlapped
each other
great thank you so much so we do have
time for a few more questions
but i do want to remind our audience
that any questions that we're unable to
answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period you know will be
addressed by our speaker
via the email address that you provided
at the time of registration
so please keep those questions coming in
as we're getting some really great ones
from the audience right now
so moving on to our next one are there
ratios of compounds that could act as
anchors for
interlab reproducibility
tough one that uh simply because human
beings are not all that reproducible
for interlab reproducibility
we can use the method we choose is to
use either an
internal standard or an external
standard
so for instance with our lab
gc mass spec system we have a sampling
loop at the front end
which takes in a standard amount of our
internal standard we use
bromofluorobenzene
and the reason we picked the
bromofluorobenzene is that you don't see
it in the breath you don't see it in the
air
and when you use that you can calibrate
it and so get to enhance your interlab
reproducibility
great thank you so much um
looks like we've got maybe one more
question that we have time for
um so dr phillips does the breath
test for lung cancer change after the
cancer is removed
surgically uh we have some very
interesting pilot data on this
in one of our earlier lung cancer
studies we
re we repeated the breath test
about a month after the patients had
undergone surgery in approximately 30
patients and we were astonished to find
that the breath signal did not change
after surgery well of course the
surgeons were very disappointed when
they heard that they thought we had a
test to see if they got all the cancer
out but i think this is telling us
something
very profound about the nature of cancer
and the
biological response to cancer in that we
are
probably just based on this very limited
subset of patients
probably not seeing a signal coming from
the tumor itself
or if it is it's not the whole story
because if that signal persists after
the tumor
is removed then we're seeing a much more
complicated background story
of what's the biochemical changes in the
body so
this is a very fruitful field for future
research
early days yet but i think it's a very
exciting area to explore further
wonderful thank you so much michael for
for your presentation and answering all
those questions
do you have any final comments for our
audience
well uh first of all thank you all very
much for tuning in to this and listening
and i know that not everybody has had
any had an opportunity to have their
questions answered
so if you have any questions please feel
free to drop me an email
and i'll do my best to answer them for
you
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration we would like to once again
thank dr michael phillips for his time
today and for his important research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor agilent
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go um you can view the webinar
on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you again for
joining us and until next time
stay safe stay healthy bye bye everyone